♪ ♪
>> Sean: DEVELOPMENTS ON THE
MUELLER PROBE TONIGHT, THE
PRESIDENT HAS SUBMITTED HIS
WRITTEN ANSWERS TO THE SPECIAL
COUNSEL SEGMENT LENGTH THE PROBE
MAY BE WRAPPING UP.
HERE NOW IS THE REACTION FROM
THE WORLD, AG EXPO IN
CALIFORNIA, HOUSE INTELLIGENCE
COMMITTEE CHAIRMAN AND
CALIFORNIA CONGRESSMAN DEVIN
NUNES.
TO ME, THE PRESIDENT HAS ALREADY
ANSWERED THOSE QUESTIONS.
IT SEEMS TO ME THAT NOT HAVING A
SUBPOENA FIGHT, HE'S NOT NOT
GOING TO BE TESTIFYING IN
PUBLIC, SEEMS TO BE WRAPPING UP,
BUT I WOULD LIKE TO SEE THE WORK
THAT YOU HAVE STARTED, AND
LINDSEY GRAHAM, AND CHARLES
GRASSLEY HAVE STARTED FINISHED.
WHERE ARE WE WITH THAT?
>> THANKS, SEAN.
WHAT I WOULD LIKE TO SEE WITH
THE MUELLER PROBE IS SOME KIND
OF PROBE INTO CHRISTOPHER STEELE
AND THE CLINTON CAMPAIGN AND
THOSE RUSSIANS.
THAT IS WHAT REALLY DISAPPOINTED
ME ABOUT ALL OF        ALL OF TH
ME ABOUT ALL OF        ALL OF TS
ME ABOUT ALL OF        ALL OF T.
ALSO, WHO LEAKED HIS NAME?
I DON'T THINK HE REALLY -- THERE
WAS NEVER ANY COLLUSION BETWEEN
THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN AND RUSSIA.
SADLY, YOU HAVE HALF OF THE
DEMOCRATS IN THIS COUNTRY THAT
BELIEVED THAT SOMEHOW THE
RUSSIANS CHANGED VOTES IN THE
LAST ELECTION, AND THE PEOPLE
WHO HAVE BEEN SPREADING THIS
POISON OUGHT TO BE ASHAMED OF
THEMSELVES.
SO I AM GLAD THAT MAYBE THIS IS
COMING TO AN END, BUT I WILL
STRESS, I STILL DON'T BELIEVE
IT.
I WON'T BELIEVE IT UNTIL I SEE
>> Sean: THEY WILL NEVER GIVE
IT UP.
>> WELL, THAT'S TRUE.
BUT TO YOUR QUESTION, I THINK
THERE IS SOME RELUCTANCE IN THE
WHITE HOUSE TO ACTUALLY GO OUT
AND RELEASE ALL THE DOCUMENTS --
THE FOUR BUCKETS AS WE CALL
THEM -- THE CARTER PAGE PFIZER,
THE THIRD RENEWAL.
WE HAVE THE BRUCE OHR 302S, AND
A FOURTH BUCKET OF EMAILS THAT
THE FBI WAS SENDING AROUND THAT
SHOWS THAT CLEARLY THEY KNEW
WHAT THEY WERE DOING BEFORE THEY
WENT TO THE FISA COURT.
>> Sean: ESPECIALLY THE FOURTH
FISA, THE THIRD RENEWAL SIGNED
BY ROD ROSENSTEIN, I'VE NEVER
READ IT, I WOULD LIKE TO READ
IT.
THE 302S, THAT IS CHRISTOPHER
STEELE, BRUCE OHR.
THE FISA APPLICATIONS
THEMSELVES, WE TALKED ABOUT THE
FOURTH BUCKET WITH THE FBI.
THE PRESIDENT SAID THAT HE WOULD
BE DUMB I COULD DECLASSIFY
AND UNREDACTED THIS.
HE STILL HASN'T DONE IT.
HOW IMPORTANT IS IT AND WHAT
WOULD IT DO TO MUTE THE NEVER
ENDING INVESTIGATIONS THAT WANT
TO GO ON?
HOW WOULD THAT MITIGATE WHAT HE
IS TRYING TO DO TO MAKE THIS GO
ON TILL THE END OF HISTORY?
>> WHAT IT DOES FOR US IS IT
GIVES CLOSURE TO THE HOUSE
REPUBLICANS AND ALL THE
INFORMATION THAT WE HAVE
UNCOVERED FOR THE LAST TWO
YEARS.
IT WOULD GIVE FINALITY TO
EVERYONE WHO WANTS TO KNOW
EXACTLY WHAT THEIR GOVERNMENT
DID TO A POLITICAL CAMPAIGN.
THAT'S WHY WE WANT THIS FISA OUT
THERE.
WE ALWAYS TALK ABOUT THIS LAST
FISA BECAUSE PEOPLE WILL LEARN
ABOUT THE INSURANCE POLICY, THEY
WILL FINALLY LEARN THE INSURANCE
POLICY THAT THEY PUT TOGETHER,
TO LEARN WHAT IT IS.
>> THE INVESTIGATION?
>> WELL, I ACTUALLY DON'T THINK
SO.
I THINK THE INSURANCE POLICY, A
LOT OF PEOPLE THOUGHT THAT BUT
WHAT WE BELIEVE THE INSURANCE
POLICY IS IS WHAT IS REMAINING
IN THE LAST FISA THAT NO ONE
KNOWS YET.
WHAT JAMES COMEY CALLED A
MOSAIC, THE OTHER FACTS THAT
THEY HAVE TO GO BEFORE THE FISA
COURT.
>> Sean: THERE IS ANOTHER FISA
AGAINST ANOTHER INDIVIDUAL?
>> NO, NO, NO.
THIS IS THE SAME CARTER PAGE
PFIZER.
REMEMBER WHEN WE CAME OUT AND
SAID THE BULK OF THE FISA WAS
MADE OF THE PHONY DOSSIER AND
THE FAKE NEWS, AND THEN YOU'VE
GOT ALL THESE PEOPLE SCRAMBLING
AROUND SAYING NO, NO, THERE WAS
ALL THIS OTHER INFORMATION?
WE WENT IN AND BEGAN TO LOOK AT
ALL THIS OTHER INFORMATION AND
FOUND OUT THAT IT TOO WAS NOT
ONLY FUNNY BUT I THINK ALSO AS
CONCERNING OR MORE CONCERNING
THAN THE ORIGINAL DOCUMENT.
>> Sean: WE WILL WORK WITH
YOU.
I'M NOT GIVING UP UNTIL ALL OF
THOSE PEOPLE THAT VIOLATED ALL
OF THESE LAWS AND COMMITTED ALL
OF THESE LIES TO COURTS AND